so in the last
kind of graphic scene of inferno
dante and virgil sees satan
up to his waist and ice
triple head winged
and he also has his mouth full
one of the reasons he can't speak in the
scene
it turns out he's chewing on
three great traitors
judas brutus and cassius
well at the very bottom of hell and the
center of the earth
in the ice
is satan
i mentioned earlier my surprise at
discovering that the bottom of the pit
was icy
i also remember the surprise that just
seeing satan for the first time
up to his waist and ice three heads
wings eating traitors
tears blood is disgusting
and i thought wow what a what a
surprising ending
after francesca
after brunetto after ulysses after guido
after ugalino after all of these stories
you would just think that the best story
of all would be reserved for
satan somewhere in the future john
milton author paradise lost is probably
grateful that
dante gave satan no words
but
here
this is what we get and this is really i
think the final turning point in the
poem
where dante sees
at last finally and simply the truth of
the inferno
so something happens to the pilgrim
right here when he beholds satan
what can we say about this
well
if you look clearly at this last figure
we're just kind of following the poem
here
we can see maybe most clearly
sin or evil
it has deformed this creature that was
once beautiful
a creature that was meant to fly
can no longer do so
it has corrupted the mouth the eyes
satan is the most frustrated being in
all of the inferno
he's literally
frozen in place from the waist down
and his wings
the attempt to fly or to extricate
himself
that's keeping all of hell frozen
and so when dante looks at this
is struck by it
and then recoils from it
this really seems to be a moment of
great insight for him
and of great learning and indeed it's
it's the moment
that will lead to the to the escape from
the pit
he's going to recoil from it he's going
to turn from it
and the ascent of the poem will begin
you